dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Shana if I here now
get this after defeating chess
go and making incredible progress in
StarCraft two scientists a deep mind
just published a paper where they claim
that Hanabi is the next frontier in AI
research and we shall stop right here I
hear you asking me Carrie after
defeating all of these immensely
difficult games now you're trying to
tell me that somehow this silly card
game is the next step
yes that's exactly what I'm saying let
me explain kanabi is a card game where
two to five players cooperate to build
five card sequences and to do that they
are only allowed to exchange very little
information
this is also an imperfect information
game which means the players don't have
all the knowledge available needed to
make a good decision they have to work
with what they have and try to infer the
rest for instance poker is also an
imperfect information game because we
don't see the cards of the other players
and the game revolves around our guesses
as to what they might have in Hanabi
interestingly it is the other way around
so we see the cards of the other players
but not our own ones the players have to
work around this limitation by relying
on each other and working out
communication protocols and infer intent
in order to win the game like in many of
the best games these simple rules
conceal a vast array of strategies all
of which are extremely hard to teach to
current learning algorithms in the paper
a free and open source system is
proposed to facilitate further research
works and assess the performance of
currently existing techniques the
difficulty level of this game can also
be made easier or harder at will from
both inside and outside the game and by
inside I mean that we can set parameters
like the number of allowed mistakes that
can be made before the game is
considered lost the outside part means
that two main game settings are proposed
one self play this is the easier case
where the AI plays with
copies of itself therefore it knows
quite a bit about its teammates and two
ad-hoc teams can also be constructed
which means that a set of agents need to
cooperate that are not familiar with
each other this is immensely difficult
when I looked at the paper I expected
that as we have many powerful learning
algorithms they would read through this
challenge with ease but surprisingly I
found out that even the easier self play
variant severely under performs compared
to the best human players and
handcrafted BOTS
there is plenty of work to be done here
and luckily you can also run it yourself
at home and train some of these agents
on a consumer graphics card note that it
is possible to create a handcrafted
program that plays this game well as we
humans already know good strategies
however this project is about getting
several instances of an AI to learn new
ways to communicate with each other
effectively again the goal is not to get
a computer program that plays Hanabi
well the goal is to get an AI to learn
to communicate effectively and work
together towards a common goal
much like chess Starcraft 2 and dota
Hanabi is still a proxy to be used for
measuring progress in AI research nobody
wants to spend millions of dollars to
play card games at work so the final
goal of deepmind
is to reuse this algorithm for other
applications where even we humans falter
I have included some more materials on
this game in the video description make
sure to have a look thanks for watching
and for your generous support and I'll
see you next time